[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with kevin mcguire
and olivia artley both with us from now
until just before midnight welcome to
both of you so to the front pages then
the metro to start with can't cook won't
cook metro leading with the words of a
conservative mp who said food banks
aren't really needed in this country and
that poor people should learn to cook
from scratch which would mean make meals
a lot cheaper
same lead for the daily mirror which
calls the comments by lee anderson a
slur on the pool
the telegraph goes with boris johnson's
announcement that the uk would send
troops to finland or sweden if russia
ever invaded them the times also making
that story its front page lead uk troops
will defend scandinavia they say
the guardian highlights a new scientific
report which claims that oil and gas
companies are planning what it calls
carbon bombs major new projects which
threaten to make the climate crisis
worse rather than improve it
the financial times leading with a
threat from the eu to retaliate if as
feared the uk government rips up the
post-brexit trade deal for northern
ireland which it says has triggered
alarm in brussels and washington
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out those front
pages while you watch the programme so
let's introduce our guest then kevin
mcguire associate editor at the daily
mirror and olivia utley assistant
comment editor at the telegraph welcome
to both of you
um so let's go to the telegraph to start
with then shall we kevin um this uh
flying trip from uh boris johnson uh to
those parts of europe that had so far
not joined up to nato and crucially one
finland which has an 810 mile border
with russia um so what did you make of
that visit today and what came out of it
yes it's signing the nordic packs uh
committing um britain to back both
countries invaded by russia even if
they're not in nato both are considering
uh joining particularly the finns and
suggesting the telegraph say that he
could send british troops which i think
is a would be a major step and you could
ask why not uh to ukraine in that case
if he's prepared to do that which would
concern me but it is where um putin has
already lost because finland has been
neutral since the second world war
sweden hasn't been in military alliances
for 200 years and now both are looking
to
nato and closer ties with other
countries because of what's happened in
ukraine so
it's it's backfired spectacularly on
putin and also on the front page of that
telegraph it's quite interesting to have
that picture of him uh in the boat with
the swedish uh prime minister of swedish
uh opposite number uh magdalena anderson
i'm surprised anyone would get in a
rowing boat with boris johnson but just
show you the uh the power of a stunt
because their pictures may not be on the
front page if they hadn't been in that
in that boat
but johnson did tweet say look they're
now both in the in the same boat but it
is it's uh it's a big encircling of
russia
whether it makes countries safer i'm not
absolutely certain it does yes we are
literally and metaphorically in the same
boat was the the tweet by uh the prime
minister certainly um the times there's
another newspaper leading on this as
well and they are pointing out that the
presidential defendant is expected to
approve his country's application for
nato membership um tomorrow all very
swift and the big defense of course is
that russia you drove this to us and
these these two nations are historically
in fact from sweden's point of view for
200 years historically neutral aren't
they olivia
yeah and it's ironic of course because
russia claimed that it was invading
ukraine in the first place to stop
ukraine joining nato which was
always incredibly unlikely and now
you've got swindler
sweden and finland both moving to to
join nato and and finland really quite
seriously um
i think i mean
it would seem
nonsensical for nato to to not accept
finland's uh
proposal because finland still has
conscription it could add a lot of
expertise and an awful lot of soldiers
to the nato forces um so of course
there's the danger there's little dishes
will poke the bear but the bear already
seems to be very firmly poked so it
looks as though finland and possibly
sweden too um which with its history of
neutrality as you say is quite
astonishing could soon be accepted into
nato and that means that
russia would have a nato border all the
way from the arctic to turkey um so
russia has been encircled and and it's
vladimir putin's own fault
well the uh the the picture of that
signing with the finnish president makes
the front page of the financial times
their lead story though moves on to what
to do about the border in the irish sea
um brussels again this paper reporting
threatening retaliation if the so-called
northern ireland protocol is ditched um
it seems you know we're not there yet
seem to be the message from ministers
today
but they're not backing down from taking
radical action is this just to appease
the dup and those unionists who are not
happy with this or or is it simply
unfair that this system is not being
used as it was intended by the european
union kevin
well boris johnson negotiated the deal
he hailed an excellent deal lord frost
who now criticizes it frequently who is
his brexit negotiator he was there he
held it as a as a great deal i think in
part with boris johnson it is to appease
brexiteers on his own back uh benchers
who have his survival in their hands if
they turn on him in demand he is gone
the dup itself in northern ireland it's
lost the election for the first time 101
years since northern ireland has created
now the nationalists came out on top
with shin fein in the election they've
paid a huge price for backing
brexit back in the referendum in 2016.
the only major party in northern ireland
didn't northern ireland vote to stay
within
the european union so he could try and
appease the the dup but the eup has got
very little leverage now in northern
ireland and the position is from the dup
appears to be and jeffrey donald
donaldson who effectively stated this
that they won't nominate a first
minister with sinn fein until the
protocol is is gone well i think there's
some willingness on the european union's
part to renegotiate the application of
it but it has to be in a
in a more constructive way than the
government regularly threatening to rip
it up
well jeffrey donaldson from the dup
speaking to sophie ridge a short time
ago here on sky news said we agreed it
in good faith and the eu have pursued a
really legalistic interpretation i
suppose the principle for them is that
they want to
have a check on items that are heading
from third party countries into the
european union which of course is what
happens um with that free border between
northern ireland and the republic of
ireland olivia so that that's always
been the rub has it not
well britain has always made it clear
that it's going to ensure that the eu
can preserve its integrity uh without
the north island protocol it could all
just be wrapped into the tca that's what
britain has been proposing all along and
i mean to say that this is just
replicating the dup is not true clearly
northern ireland is not functioning
properly at the moment there are
businesses all over northern ireland
that have massive problems with the
protocol as it is now and the dup i mean
i'm sorry but the dup does still have
huge leverage it's not wasn't a
nationalist walk over in those northern
ireland elections um if you take all the
unionists put together which was very
very split then you know we're looking
at equal numbers if not the union unions
had the slight edge um and also the dup
can't appoint that the the first
minister and the deputy first minister
work together in northern ireland that's
under the terms of the good friday
agreement and without the dup uh we
can't have a functioning government so
basically the province is completely at
a standstill and something has to be
done the government's offering
everything it can to the eu to try and
make this work the eu is not budging at
all and is proposing this enormous
retaliation and it's hard to see what
what liz trust can do other than exactly
what she's doing right now
well we will certainly see what happens
with that story but let's move on to
effectively a cost of living
crisis story um with a with a new twist
obviously in the metro
a tory mp has insisted there is little
need for food banks instead blaming
people who cannot cook and cannot budget
this is lee anderson kevin
yeah he is on say meals can be made for
as little as 30 i think the metro's got
the the wrong headline there khan could
won't cook they always like their little
puns and players on words but i think
uh representing the fury art anderson
would have been um
uh more relevant here because the uh the
trussell trust is giving out more than
two million food parcels a year there
was a report by the food foundation a
few days ago showing two million adults
in britain now don't eat every day
because they can't
afford it there is a real cost of living
crisis the government acknowledges that
but lee anderson uh he used to be a
labor counselor he's now gone over uh to
the right of the uh conservative party
he likes to shout his mouth off of
course he
remember made himself a bit of an idiot
uh during the euros when he said he
wouldn't watch england play because
players were taking the knee well i'd
like to know if he really kept that all
the way up to the final and didn't watch
any of it he said he didn't but i wonder
if he sneaks a look at the tv timing out
again i think he's just speaking from uh
absolute ignorance uh well the day email
also uh effectively going on what to do
about well a how to raise funds and b
how to then distribute them uh they go
rishi warms to an energy windfall tax
plan there's always been a sense of that
hasn't there and in fact
what to do will be the subject of
an away day cabinet
is our understanding in the midlands
tomorrow the financial times is also
quoted as reporting the government is
prepared to announce a new support
package to help shield households from a
further jump in energy bills suggesting
that rishi sunet will make an
announcement in august around the time
when the energy regulator prepares the
next price cap but is it safe to say
olivia that something will be done
something will be done but what the
government seems to keep doing is these
sort of away days or there was a
brainstorming session the other day
where they talk about measures that
might get a bit more money um into the
treasury and it all seems to be sort of
stop gap solutions there doesn't seem to
be a sense that the government sort of
has a big plan and you've got uh we saw
some pages from inside the ft earlier
and um one of them was robert shrimsley
article saying that the only thing that
the government can do now anything
that's left to do is to lower taxes
which does seem to be the sort of
elephant in the room all of these small
handouts to people to help them pay one
gas bill at a time isn't exactly a
strategy um and it's it's all just
sticking plasters and it can't really
last for very long
and i don't think a cabinet a weight is
going to solve a proper conservative
government offering to cut people's
taxes well that might make a bit of a
difference uh growth figures for the
first three months of the year are to be
released by the
ons tomorrow morning we'll see how that
goes in the meantime to the daily
telegraph kevin and there'll be a
crackdown we understand on children who
are skipping school in the wake of the
coveted pandemic this is nadim zahawi
writing in the delhi telegraph
now i'd like to see the detail of how
this will actually actually work but
there's no doubt there's a big problem
the children's commissioner for england
uh recently said that there's something
like 2 million pupils who missed about
10 percent of schooling in the autumn
and that is a huge problem and because
some kids stopped going to school they
haven't gotten into the habit of going
back and
their parents carers aren't on making
them do it it's a serious problem this
because a lot of education has been mr
over covered if it continues to be like
this they're going to really struggle in
later life in every every respect
including the the jobs market but
the tackling truancy has been a
government policy of all governments of
all colors for a long time and
of course attendance records uh are part
of it ofsted ratings so schools do take
it seriously uh local authorities take
it seriously i just want to really see
what he will do that is actually
different to what's being done now so
the trial of the
what word to you is not sure but anyway
the trial that is ongoing uh double page
spread in the metro um you know this is
uh this is all mada manner of fodder for
all newspapers everywhere is it not
olivia
yeah it's a really brilliant trial i'm
particularly enjoying the um the court
sketches are just great they really sum
up what's going on in the room you feel
like you're there um there are some
great stuff there on the metro about uh
peter andre uh
i think it was vardy saying that
something about him having it having a
chipper laughter being used as as her
not respecting people's privacy um it's
everything you could possibly want in a
celebrity court trial all in one go
basically um and
enjoyable to read if i'm allowed to say
that yeah well indeed well i mean you
know she's in she's in tears in the
court let's let's caveat it with that
shall we and but this is all about
whether or not she effectively let a
newspaper or a newspaper know
information um
and uh you know even even the evidence
on that is fascinating kevin
it is because of course she she denies
licking stories uh about uh
you know rooney she says she didn't do
it however there's
messages come to light that she wanted
to leak stories about another footballer
danny drinkwater after you had a car
crash it says there's only a fleeting
intention never intended but i didn't
want to be paid by the sun for it which
in the event said they'd heard the story
from the
police it's a real case not i watch it
no
it may not make me a good man to be
enjoying other people's misery but you
what you watch this uh and it is it is
like a theatrical show a farce it is a
reason why don't sue for defamation
unless you're absolutely clear
of your grounds and the case because
rebecca vardy is uh in the stand and is
on trial as much as colleen rooney and
she hasn't come out of it well in my
view you can say that because of the
nature of the case it was a criminal
case we couldn't but it's absolutely
riveting
we've got more than a week of this to go
it's great isn't it
let's move to the bottom of the front
page of the daily telegraph which is the
idea that incentives visitors face a fee
to spend a penny this is tourists but
also
owners of holiday homes uh which the
paper says shows um the difficulty or
the anger the hostility towards those
who
have taken up some of the property in
the area
yeah i mean it's amazing this this real
cultural that's going on in cornwall i
spend my father-in-law lives in cornwall
i spend quite a bit of time there and
the amount they hate tourists is getting
a little bit out of control and second
home owners are are just as bad if not
worse and you can understand how some of
the people of somewhere likes and ives
feel because these second homeowners all
come down for the holidays um and then
they disappear and leave these areas as
ghost towns for the rest of the year um
on the other hand cornwall does get
a lot of its uh
you know it's a comedy its economy is
basically based off tourism so to to
drive out all of the tourists would
probably be a mistake but there really
is a very serious cultural going on down
in cornwall between ordinary cornish
people who've lived there all their
lives and and the huge brigade of sort
of you know fulham decamping to to
cornwall every summer every christmas et
cetera um and it's hard to see how it's
going to end happily especially if if us
paul london is sounds like goes to lou
when we go down to cornwall and a quick
minute if you don't mind on page seven
of the metro the minister of silly talks
um harriet harry enfield's 1990s sketch
show deployed by uh by him today
yeah michael gove uh the the leveling up
leveling down uh secretary using a
scouse accent and an american accent in
an interview and lisa nandy let his
labor shannon coming off and say look
this isn't again you know what he's
under a lot of pressure on that but this
is weird i thought when he was dancing
badly in a
uh in an aberdeen club it was rather
it was rather endearing but to
you know cost a living crisis which is
huge and people are suffering